esperado por su Aliado japonés el
presidente de Estados Unidos Fue
recibido por el Primer Ministro
la oportunidad para recordar la
alineación de los dos países en uno de
los temas principales de la Cumbre del
g7 la guerra en Ucrania
defendemos valores comunes en particular
apoyamos al valiente pueblo ucraniano en
la defensa de su territorio soberano
Rusia es responsable de esta brutal
agresión palabras que resuenan aún más
aquí en Hiroshima una ciudad que fue
devastada por una bomba nuclear del
ejército estadounidense en agosto de
1945 mientras los líderes del g7
condenan las amenazas nucleares del
presidente ruso discutirán el refuerzo
de la samsunges contra Moscú
especialmente contra el comercio de
diamantes rusos también intentarán
encontrar una solución para evitar que
Rusia eluda estas sanciones otro tema de
la agenda es las relaciones con China
cuya posición militar regional es
preocupante para el Primer Ministro
japonés el apoyo de Estados Unidos en la
región es crucial la alianza Japón
Estados Unidos es la piedra angular de
la paz y la estabilidad en la región
indopacífica la relación Japón Estados
Unidos no es solo de seguridad es sólida
en todos los ámbitos ante la amenaza de
los obstáculos comerciales de Beijing el
g7 también debatirá cómo protegerse pero
en Hiroshima la Cumbre será también una
oportunidad para que fumikishida anime a
sus invitados en particular a Reino
Unido Francia y Estados Unidos a reducir
sus arsenales nucleares